foreign
[Music]
cancellation day we turn to a woman
named Jana Frye who's a current
occupation is life coach this is not the
first time that a life coach has been
featured in this segment as you know if
someone calls themselves a life coach
it's a Surefire sign that their own life
is in utter shambles you know when you
think about somebody hitting rock bottom
you probably imagine a person lying in
the gutter disheveled passed out drunk
homeless that's not quite Rock Bottom
there is a level deeper more debased and
pathetic and disgraceful than that and
that's the level where you become a life
coach
people can't who can't do teach which
means that if you don't know how to live
a successful life you teach other people
how to live a successful life except
that your advice is sure to be quite
terrible
before we get to the actual reason why
Yana is the subject of our cancellation
today I want to share just for context I
guess one little morsel of her wisdom
this is the first thing that popped up
when I searched her name on YouTube so I
didn't do a lot of digging but I think
this is good enough it gives us a feel
for who this person is here She is
delivering some some real uh some real
important life coaching listen
thanks
you are the one living and writing your
story
there is no one else
you are the only person who is
responsible for all the pain and
pleasure in your life
you are the only one who has the power
to create or destroy
everything around you
and the sooner
we all remember it realize it
[Music]
we can restore peace
in our society
you are the only one who has the power
to create or destroy everything in your
life not not only is this obviously
nonsense just a lot of self affirmation
mumbo jumbo it also sounds like the kind
of thing that a comic book supervillain
would say to himself in the mirror you
are the only one with the power to
destroy and create it events as an
extreme level of narcissism I mean
narcissism that diverges into delusion
that's something we should keep in mind
as we move on to the story that has gone
viral this week uh centering around this
woman The Daily Mail reports quote a
woman who divorced her husband while he
was suffering from testicular cancer has
revealed why she has no regrets Jana fry
a life coach from Saint Petersburg
Russia who now lives in Singapore got
married when she was just 22 years old
and looking back she wishes she hadn't
tied the knot before she was 30. her
ex-husband who was 15 years her senior
was diagnosed with testicular cancer
three months into her marriage and she
stayed with him for another five years
even before his diagnosis Jana said her
husband always was always one to drown
in self-pity and after years of mental
anguish she called it quits much to her
in-laws disdain I rushed into that
marriage I don't think women should
marry before 30. we have no idea who we
are and we don't know what a good
partner is for us the 40 year old
explained yeah I met her husband about a
year before they tied the knot
and while they had a good relationship
she believes it never stood a chance
after he fell unwell because of the toll
his illness took on them both
now from here we're told all about
Jana's husband's cancer diagnosis which
obviously affected Yana herself most of
all she is the main character she is the
one with the power to create and destroy
the whole universe revolves around her
and now her husband's terminal illness
revolves around her too her his terminal
illness was cramping her style ruining
her vibe The Daily Mail continues people
react in one of two ways to critical
illnesses I've seen it over and over she
said
the first type was how my husband
unfortunately was the people who drowned
in self-pity the second type of people
are those who are instead concerned with
everyone around them
yes how dare her husband uh pity himself
because he had cancer he should have
been pitying her instead
you know this this marriage isn't big
enough for two people to be pitied
continuing uh quote Jana said that at
the time Society was less aware of
mental health so much so that even
medical professionals never asked how
she was coping
I was in a State of Shock when I first
heard the diagnosis it took me six
months to be even be able to say the
word cancer she said we saw different
kinds of doctors not a single person
ever offered me help they never asked do
you need a support system are you part
of a Counseling group I was hoping for
the best with my husband's cancer but
then years went by I started to lose
hope it was five years with all the
treatments and started to change the
Dynamics within our relationship it
wasn't until the fifth year that I
started to think about leaving
yes how dare those parents how dare
those doctors you know the cancer
doctors not ask her they should begin
with that
like how is your mental yeah I mean you
you're dying of cancer but what about
you how's your mental health how are you
feeling
I mean all this it's understandable
though isn't it I mean she gave the guy
five years to get over his annoying
cancer phase but he had the gall to
continue being sick even though his
sickness was clearly impacting her
Mental Health
so she finally decided to file for
divorce reading again quote but I felt
like I couldn't say anything when
someone is dying next to you you feel
like you can't talk about your own
well-being because you compare it to
their suffering Jana said that
everything changed for her when one of
her friends took their own life and she
attended their open casket funeral which
brought home her own fragile mental
state it was my first funeral and it was
very shocking in my mind at the time
suicide became an option even though I
had never considered that before I was
in such a bad State she explained it was
very clear to me that if I didn't save
myself I was probably going to die so
Jana made the decision to divorce her
dying ex-husband and it was an
understandably difficult time for both
of them his main focus was more and more
about him at the beginning of his
treatment he was still checking in on me
he felt even more pity for himself
because of the divorce she said
pretty egotistical of that guy he has
cancer his wife leaves him
that's no reason to get all upset
if you're like me you probably have a
running list of books you'd like to read
on your phone or in the back of your
notebook I'll be honest I know I'm not
going to get to read all those books
which is why I'm so grateful for short
form short form is the best way to learn
the ideas from all these books that
you've been wanting to read but haven't
gotten around to it they make the best
guides to non-fiction books their
summaries are incredibly detailed giving
you all the main ideas without all the
fluff fluff unlike other e-learning
services short firm form offers entire
chapter breakdowns smart insights
interactive exercises to help you apply
the ideas you learn I use short form to
help cross some books off my list like
the life-changing magic of tidying up
and the power of fun which are some
great reads those are exactly the kinds
of books that you know I'm really
reading in real life and these books
really help me to unpack some deep
traumas in my spirit and I think come to
sort of a Oneness within my soul
and it's helped me to live a more
affirmative and positive life in a lot
of ways anyway short forms new AI
browser extension tool offers short form
summaries to everything across the
internet even YouTube videos this tool
is available at no extra cost new and
existing paid users can access it
without limitations short form publishes
new book guides and articles every week
and subscribers get to vote on what
books they'll cover next as well to get
a free trial and an additional 25 off an
annual subscription join short form
through my exclusive Link at
shortform.com Walsh or click the link in
the description that's short form.com
slash Welsh now anyway we're told that
Jana left her husband then he died and
she found out about it on Facebook which
was very offensive to her personally she
insists that someone in her husband's
family should have thought to reach out
to the horrible wench who left him on
his deathbed to personally alert her
that the man she abandoned had passed
away
but because she was not personally told
she was once again the victim so you
notice the theme playing out it's not
very subtle janafry is the victim of
every Misfortune that happens around her
even if it's not happening to her she's
still the main victim and everything
that happens is really about her her
husband's cancer is about her her
friend's funeral was about her
her husband or then her ex-husband's
death was about her
all about her the goddess who who alone
possesses the power to create and
Destroy and apparently she chooses to
destroy she destroyed her marriage her
vows her husband's will to live
a trail of Destruction in her wake which
she is now brought into a new marriage
which she will of course also abandon
the second that she detects that the
focus has shifted even for a moment away
from her and the only difference there
is that the second husband will deserve
to be abandoned by his wife given that
he married her knowing what a
self-absorbed monster she is you get
what you pay for as they say
now as for the lesson that Jana has
learned from all this is exactly what
you think the lesson would be quote I'm
finally learning to love myself and
accept myself for who I am she said
revealing that she's now a stepmother to
her second husband's son and hopes to
have children of her own
Jana's hoping that by sharing her
experience other people especially women
will find the courage to do what is
right for themselves even if it comes at
the cost of social disapproval I feel we
especially women are just usually
brought up in this mentality to serve
others but when you get to go against it
you'll learn a lot about resilience and
self-awareness you said you learn how to
not crack under the pressure of the
world being so close to death has made
me appreciate life much more
wasn't that nice you know the horrible
agonizing death of her husband helped
her to appreciate life and love herself
so really it was all worth it when you
think about it
now I don't have to explain why this
woman is awful and I don't have to tell
you that she's a narcissistic soulless
hobgoblin I don't have to explain that
she is so self-absorbed that she has now
collapsed in on herself like a dying
star and turned into a black hole that
obliterates everything in its orbit
um that all we can see
the important point to take from this
tragic tale a story equal parts sad and
revolting is that it is the inevitable
consequence of the love yourself first
mentality that is shared by many people
in modern culture
anyone who believes that the point of
life is to pursue your own happiness
first and foremost as an end to itself
and at the highest form of love is
self-love and that self-love is
foundational and at first you have to
love yourself and think about loving
yourself before you can love anybody
else
um when of course the you know the
reality is the opposite stop thinking
about yourself for five seconds work on
loving the people around you loving and
serving the people around you and if you
do that and you stop thinking about
yourself you're going to turn back at a
you know one day and notice oh you know
I feel pretty good about myself too that
happens as a byproduct of focusing on
loving other people
but in our culture we have it exactly
backwards focus on loving yourself first
and then you can love others and until
you can love yourself everyone else be
damned
but everybody with this mentality is no
different from Jana Frye if they haven't
abandoned a cancer-stricken spouse it's
only because they haven't yet had a
cancer stricken spouse to abandon and if
they did have a cancer chicken spouse
and they didn't abandon him they did at
least sulk and pout and emanate
resentment and Scorn
um sacrificial love is a foreign concept
to these people
the idea of serving someone else the
idea of loving the other and giving of
themselves is repulsive
and this is the attitude that is
intentionally instilled in children from
a young age the attitude that many of
them bring into adulthood and keep
through their lives
destroying one relationship after
another as they alienate everyone around
them
now we know that of course uh justice
will come for Jana fries it does for all
of these sorts of people it'll come when
it's her turn to shuffle off this Mortal
coil and she looks around to find that
there's no one there for her
and she'll die alone just as her husband
did
that's where her self-love will lead her
it's where it leads everyone
and that is why she is today canceled
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts